Yeah. Yeah. So I'm not, I still procrastinate,
but I have, like, I went through this big, like self-improvement phase.
And so yeah. I've like really read a lot about how to not procrastinate. Um,
so there's this, like,
there's a famous paper that has this like equation of procrastination.
And it basically says like, yeah, so there's like, there's like four,
four elements of procrastination.
Ever had problems with your Mac,
bunch of garbage making it unbearable to use. Maybe it's time for a clean.
No, not like that. Nope.
That's not it either.
Definitely not that you've given up. Don't worry.
I got just the thing for you.
Presenting clean my Mac X by Mac Paul, our sponsor for today,
finally,
a legit Mac cleaning app that actually does what it says instead of putting
even more viruses on your computer.
So the jet with all of these different features,
you can deep,
clean your Mac and so many ways it will make your Mac as good as new.
The UI is beautiful.
So sleep makes me want it clean every day.
You can clean up, speed up and protect your Mac with this app.
That's how powerful this tool is. Honestly,
this app should be the first app you install on any Mac so you
can monitor apps or files that don't spark joy
and denial. Marie condo style.
Hey, Joma, how's your Mac doing? Aren't you happy?
You installed clean my Mac acts. Great.
Find out more about clean my Mac X and download a free trial for
free with the link in the description below.
So yeah, so I like how you, you know,
study using like Lee coder strategies and stuff like that.
But what about in general? Cause like, um,
I heard that you graduated high school pretty early, right? Yeah. I,
I skipped like a total two grades. Oh my God. Wait.
So when did you go to college again? Yeah, so I was, so I went to college.
I was 16 and my first year of college. Um, but then I was 19,
but yeah, so I, then I took a, I took,
I took an extra semester to graduate because I switched majors late to see us.
I see. Okay. And then in co do you have any tips for college, you know,
for like studying or sleeping? You study a lot to get into college,
like SATs and stuff. Uh, I studied some messages, but I wasn't very motivated.
I was motivated like during your college years? Um, I think, uh,
like sophomore year and up, but like freshman year, I really like up.
Like I got, I got like a really low GPA.
What was it like sub sub one.
[Inaudible] actually, yeah. Tony,
I thought you thought you were going to say like 2.9 because that's my
cumulative possible. Yes,
please. I think you told me that.
Like that first year, first semester I was at a certain school,
like a better school and then I did really badly cause I did notice study. Okay.
And then I transferred to that, like no name, liberal arts college?
Yeah. Okay. Wait, sub one. Does that mean that you felt like most like.
Yeah, like absentees or absent C minus it's like basically I didn't go to class.
It wasn't that I like went to class study. Didn't like did bad. Like just like,
I just like, I didn't like depressed or something. I just didn't go to class.
Yeah.
Okay. you, you know why it's because you were too young. Do you want to go?
I honestly, yeah, probably.
I wasn't. I wasn't ready to work for emotionally mature.
For college.
I think I met a girl that was also 16 years old when she started first year. Um,
I could tell that she was like, Ima Ima like emotionally immature.
And because of that, I think she made a lot of like dumb decisions,
like prematurely saying like, Oh, this is what I want to do. Passion, blah,
blah, blah. And then when things don't work out, she freaks out why?
Because during your whole high school you would be smoking. Right. And you know,
you could do it. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I wasn't, yeah. I wasn't ready at all. Yeah. You know, what's wrong.
Society nowadays. People forget to deal with being bored,
forget to deal with it. They don't know how to,
they don't know how to deal with being bored, you know?
And then because of that,
they have these like advanced AP or like the skip grade and strip that doesn't
that isn't like, wait, I don't, I don't see that.
The connection between like I was with you for part of that.
And then you jumped through this like AP like.
Okay. Not AP, but like just skipping grades. Yeah. You know what I mean? Like,
like for example.
Oh, you're saying like, Oh God.
You know, when,
when you're in grade three and you're smarter than everyone else, then,
then you go or whatever. Yeah.
But back then we didn't, we didn't have these like AP. Right. People just,
you know, just learn at the same pace as everyone else.
But you could do something for boredom. You just stay in class or you think of,
right? Yeah. Yeah. That's true. I think, I think, I think that's yeah.
And it was uh, Oh yeah. Study. Yeah.
Oh, yes. Studying in general. Yeah. Yes. I didn't,
I didn't study at all freshman year. Um, and generally like, I,
I never really became a good studier until like,
like maybe like one year out of college and then like,
and then like a year after college,
like I wasn't a good student in college cause like my, my chemo GPA,
even in my new school was like just under three. Um,
I was like, w w what does that in terms of letter grades like a B like, yeah.
Yeah. Um, and so like, and I had,
I got like decent grades in my CS classes and my like philosophy classes,
but basically when I didn't care about a class, I just like, didn't do for it.
Um, but, um, I think that's kind of always been like my emo,
like if I really care about something, I go like a hundred percent, like all in.
Um, but if I don't then I don't.
Um, but yeah. Okay. And then, uh, yeah, I, I guess,
I guess the thing that I want to know more is like, um, you know,
how do you prevent procrastination?
How do you study for like long periods of time and keeping motivated? Yeah.
Yeah. So I'm not, I still procrastinate, but I have, like,
I went through this big, like self-improvement phase. And so yeah.
I've like really read a lot about how to not procrastinate. Um, so there's this,
like, there's a famous paper that has this like equation of procrastination.
And it basically says like, yeah, so there's like, there's like four,
four elements of procrastination. And basically, um,
like one element is a expect, expect expectancy.
And basically it means like expecting expectancy is low. Like,
you don't think it's going to happen or like, what do you mean? Like,
basically you might procrastinate something because you don't think you're going
to do well. Uh, so it's like, you don't think.
Oh, it doesn't even matter. Yeah. I don't need to leave Cole.
I'm not going to get jobs.
Expectancy means like, you know,
your confidence is going to go well or something like that. I might assemble it,
but basically four elements and another woman is like the reward. Um,
and then other elements like, like attention. And then, so basically ideas,
like you want to like, raise like back expectancy and like decrease the tension,
like attention, distraction, and like increase the reward. Uh, and so there's,
there's just like famous,
like flow chart of like ways you can like do that is a flow chart while there's
like this like, like graph thing. Um, I'll find that like, but basically, uh,
yeah, there's a bunch of different techniques. Like I mentioned,
like don't break the chain and then another one is, um, it's called.
We explained the don't break the chance since it's going to be a different
video. Oh, yes. Yeah.
So don't break. The chain is basically like, you try to do, uh,
whatever you want to do for a little bit of every day.
And then as you do for that day, you just like make a Mark of it. Uh,
and then like you imagine like a big calendar, uh,
you basically want to build up a chain of like exes on marks. Um,
and then as the chain goes up, it becomes like more and more like,
there's like inertia or like momentum.
Like you don't want to break it as it gets longer.
You just want to keep it going, right?
Yes. Yes, dude. I've been trying to, and I got like a streak. Yeah.
I've been trying to no fat for awhile. Yeah. I guess the chain is,
it's just like the idea of like a streak, like a snap snap streak.
It came about before all of that. But anyway, uh, then another idea is like, uh,
Pomodoros where you basically just try to.
Dude, I minute I heard that word, like, I don't know what it is,
but I see people making videos of that,
where they just study and people watch that. Yeah. So
just by doing nothing and it was on my door.
Pomodora I guess it's the initial meaning is I guess like some kind of like
timer, like tomato timer. Okay. Yeah.
And so basically you just said it and you work for twenty-five minutes and then
you take a five minute break and you repeat, that's literally all it is.
But the reason why it works is because opt-in procrastination happens.
Cause like you can't get started or you don't know where to get started.
So like, or it's intimidating. Right. So it's a lot more intimidating to like,
think about studying for four hours then is to think about just let's just do 25
minutes. Right. And so it's like, it's basically just about breaking it down.
Yeah. I think starting is the hardest part, like even for videos or anything.
Okay. So I've, I've been unemployed for a while, right? Yeah. And then Holy.
I told myself, I was like, Oh, I'm going to make videos and do all that.
I didn't do anything. You know? And,
and I didn't do anything with my time either because like, it just so hard,
like starting. Right. And I think that's the hardest part,
but then once it gets started, the flow is a lot.
Exactly. Yeah. That's another thing. Right? Like flow, that's a big,
I think if you can get into a state of flow, so flow is basically just like, um,
like you're totally immersed. You don't notice time passing and like,
if you can just stay flow,
it's basically impossible to be like distracted or to like procrastinate. Like,
cause you're just like totally in the moment, like, like mindfulness,
like a hundred percent attention. Um,
and so you can get to that state by gamefication or by, you know,
being intrinsically interested in like the journey then that helps a lot.
Oh, that makes sense. I was in the flow when I was drawing. Actually,
there's one thing that, uh, I want to talk about for procrastination.
I always procrastinate,
but I procrastinate by doing other stuff that's productive.
Yeah. So actually that's a,
that's actually a technique it's called structured procrastination.
Basically the, imagine a list of things you like have to do or like want to do,
then you think about like,
so the thing on the top is like something you really need to do,
but you don't want to do it,
but there's something else right below it that's like also pretty important,
but you will,
you don't want to do it like the amount to which you don't want to do it isn't
as high as the first one.
So you can procrastinate the first one we did the second one. Right.
And so eventually as long as the first one,
isn't like super important then still. Yeah. You're still yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. It's like, yeah. That makes a lot of sense. Yeah.
That's pretty cool. I remember, wait, what was my procrastination thing? Like,
it's probably like, Oh, back then. It was like, Oh,
I don't want to work on fate. Like at Facebook for some.
And then instead of just videos, videos. Yeah.
I think that's why I was so productive. And then when I meet to make videos.
Because it becomes like a chore it's like not. Yeah.
And then I think then I did laundry.
Yeah. Can just clean up or yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
But the issue is that is whenever there's like the top priority things is really
important that you have to do it, but yeah. But then again,
if it's really that important and there's a timeline, sorry,
there's like a deadline. I usually do pretty well right before this.
Definitely. Yeah. No, me too. I think. Um, yeah. That's another thing it's like,
uh, like the force of the desperation. Yeah, of course. Yeah. But it's like,
it's also risky because it's the one thing I've noticed personally is that like,
as I build up the history of doing stuff right before the deadline,
and as I've built up a history of successfully do the margin becomes smaller and
smaller because like I'm afraid my brain is like, dude,
there's no need to panic. I've done this five minutes.
Like let's just do four minutes this time. Right.
And then eventually it's going to crash eventually.
It's not going to work anymore. Yeah.
So you need to like trick a brain and saying like, don't be that confident.
Like this might be the time or like you just like fail and the next time.
Lisa. Yeah. Yeah. And then, but the issue at work, I feel like, um,
I feel like at work,
a lot of deadlines are actually like soft deadlines self-imposed yeah. No.
And I've been, self-imposed even worse than that.
Like imagine a PM does either or a manager tells you to do that.
They have a margin of error. Also.
They actually know that you might not that you know, and then I don't know,
I've learned to be like, he's doing leisure at work,
but without the negative consequences, sometimes, you know,
it's like pushing back, pushing back. Yeah. No, but that's a good,
that's a good skill to pushing back. Cool. Cool. Cool.